parmi les héros de vos feuilleton bien
aimé il en est qui sont arrivés à la
télévision française déjà précédé d'une
forte renommée
c'est le cas par exemple de l'homme
invisible l'homme invisible avant de
venir nous rendre visite l'hiver dernier
avait enchanté plusieurs générations de
petits gars aient bien cet homme
invisible
je les ai vus oui j'ai eu l'heureuse
fortune de pouvoir le rencontrer et de
l'interviewer dans un bureau de la
télévision française
et là je lui ai posé quelques questions
que vous vouliez peut-être vu même lui
poser
mais chez brady je vous sais gré de nous
avoir consacré quelques instants je vous
en prie je suis très heureux d'être ici
je sais à quel point vous êtes occupés
on a toujours quelques minutes à
accorder à ses amis vous amis sont
nombreux et passionné par vos aventures
je le sais bien je crois que voulez vous
poser quelques questions si vous
permettez bien sûr mais auparavant je
vais vous demander la permission de me
débarrasser ses bandelettes ça tient
très très chaud ont bien sûr je réduis
penser - m mais à ce propos j'ai
l'impression que j'en avais un peu plus
d'habitude c'est exact imaginez vous que
j'ai eu un accident de voiture
pas grave non non eh bien écoutez je
vous en prie en novembre net j'aurais dû
y penser maintenant c'est tout à fait
normal avec moi ne sait pas très bien
comment se comporter je suis habitué ne
bougez pas j'en ai pour une seconde vous
avez c'est plus difficile à mettre 40 v
vous n'êtes pas aimable de mettre ainsi
à l'aise monsieur brady à la vérité on
est un peu désemparés devant vous moi
même parfois encore je suis désemparé
tenez par exemple croyez vous que ce
soit facile de se couper les ongles
quand on ne voit pas le bout de ses
doigts
cher monsieur brady nous avons bien du
mal à imaginer votre vie quotidienne
voyez vous nous recevons beaucoup de
lait de téléspectateurs qui nous posent
des questions sur vous je vais tenter
d'y répondre mais auparavant voulez-vous
me permettra d'enlever mon imperméable
ça j'y vois pas d'inconvénient mais
c'est que je vais être complètement
invisible et parfois sa déroute mes
interlocuteurs je suis brady je voudrais
vous poser une question à ce propos une
question indiscrète
quand vous êtes un visiteur
êtes vous habiller et bien au début il
m'a été très difficile de rendre les
vêtements invisible la texture des
textiles et peu favorable ah oui alors
alors l'hiver je m'efforçais de ne pas
faire trop d enquête à l'extérieur ne
suivra dit je vous écoute parler vous
dites des phrases très compliqué comme
la texture des textiles pour un anglais
vous parler fort bien notre langue mais
je suis doublé en français cher monsieur
ah oui je vous ai amené quelques photos
j'ai pensé que ça pourrait vous
intéresser à vous êtes forte aimable
vous savez c'est pas du tout comme mode
de parler avec vous parce que on ne sait
vraiment pas où diriger son regard et
puis à l'endroit d'où viendra vous assez
ma bouche 10 cm au dessus il ya mes yeux
a alors comme ça je vais essayer de me
débrouiller je crains fort que ces
photos intéresse pas grand monde
ce sont surtout des souvenirs pour moi
mais si mais si c'est passionnant vous
pensez l'album de photos de l'homme
invisible
tiens c'est notre dame sa wii et
souvenirs d'un voyage à paris
je suis au premier plan devant la
cathédrale et je ne vous voit pas et non
à huy et les gentils ce petit garçon là
c'est mon filleul patrick qu'en est il
pour tenir en r que le seigneur mes bras
ah oui suisse mais bien pour aller à par
magie je vais vous faire une confidence
je suis invisible oui jma beat plus haut
le regard commun montez votre regard
plus haut vous sauriez poitrine oui je
suis un peu perdu 6 1
non ça c'est les photos personnelles je
m'entends haut et puis après tout tant
pis
elle s'appelait frédéric m je pense que
ça peut être toujours comme ça à venir
elle avait 18 ans et moins vingt sept
ans 40 à londres pendant le blitz
il sait vous oui il fait beau il fait
très beau
oui
laissez moi prendre votre main frédéric
heures ou nemours au peter ma mère vous
voyez
aux yeux du monde vous êtes seul
frédéric à oui ça n'est que de mal peter
peter peter mon amour comme on est bien
tous les deux et oui mais alors rien l
élan expliqué à monsieur le maire c'est
un fauteuil vide qui va dire oui bien
sûr les gens sont bêtes ils ne sont pas
préparés à recevoir une découverte de
cette importance d'ailleurs les
spectateurs nous pose souvent la
question quel est le principe qui
président votre invisibilité aux il est
très simple c'est une permutation
moléculaire à synchronisme déphasé une
permutation moléculaires basés sur le
changement des phases du synchronisme
ah oui mesdames et messieurs vous
demandiez sous-le-vent et bien il s'agit
du et vous avez trouvé ça bien longtemps
j'étais tout jeune